we cannot defend ourselves against an
enemy that we cannot define there's a
lot of confusion about how to define
al-qaida is it just the group in
Pakistan
what about affiliates in Iraq Syria
Somalia Yemen in West Africa and their
affiliates we must answer the question
what is al-qaeda the US military sees
itself as legally barred from pursuing
individuals who have attacked Americans
unless they are affiliated with al-qaeda
the al-qaeda leadership has recognized
some groups and any reasonable
definition must include these groups as
part of al-qaeda the question is to what
extent we include locally oriented
groups and there is disagreement over
this the Obama administration has used
the question as to whether al-qaida core
ordered an attack to decide whether
al-qaeda was responsible the issue with
using the term al-qaida core is that
there's disagreement as to what that
even means administration officials
appear to be using it to mean the group
of individuals that are with Ayman
al-zawahiri in Pakistan today but others
define it as veterans of the al-qaeda
organization these are individuals who
are active in al-qaeda on September 11th
in 2001 today they dispersed out of
Pakistan and some even sit at the head
of affiliates a prime example is the
group in Yemen the leader of al-qaeda in
the Arabian Peninsula is also the
general manager of al-qaeda as a whole
in London imagine a network uniting
like-minded groups across the Muslim
world that's far more expansive than the
al-qaida core that were currently
focused on today
that group is hemmed in by American
troops in Afghanistan and the threat of
US drone strikes in Pakistan for the
time being but when we define al-qaeda
we need to look at how the group sees
itself that means looking at how groups
like the jamal network in egypt and the
masked brigade in the sajo both of which
have relationships with al-qaeda
affiliates relate to al-qaeda but as we
look to define the broader al-qaeda
network calling something al-qaeda does
not necessarily warrant the immediate
use of military action excluding large
parts in the network does
strategic failure we must not define the
enemy down
you